♪ ♪
>> Juan: A NEW JERSEY
HIGH SCHOOL UPSETTING STUDENTS
AND SOME PARENTS AFTER
IMPLEMENTING A NEW POLICY TO
MAKE THE CHEERLEADING TEAM MORE
INCLUSIVE.
THE SCHOOL SAYING THE SQUAD MUST
NOW ACCEPT EVERYONE OR BE
DISBANDED.
THIS DECISION COMING UP TO ONE
PARENT COMPLAINED WHEN HER CHILD
DIDN'T MAKE THE CUT FOLLOWING
TRYOUTS LAST MONTH.
GREG, IS THIS A CASE OF, YOU
KNOW, --
>> Kimberly: HE WAS A
CHEERLEADER.
>> Greg: I WAS.
>> Juan: IS THAT RIGHT?
I DIDN'T KNOW IF YOU ARE HAVING
FUN AT HIS EXPENSE.
>> Greg: A SECRET I WAS TRYING
TO KEEP FROM AMERICA.
>> Juan: DO YOU THINK IT'S
WEAKENING OUR CHILDREN?
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW.
HERE IS MY FEELING.
IT'S A SMALL LOCAL STORY OVER A
BEEF OVER A CHEERLEADING CHOICE.
SOME PARENTS CUT TICKED OFF.
NOW IT'S A NATIONAL STORY.
I'M A LITTLE SCARED.
NONE OF THE TEACHERS OR COACHES
MAKE ENOUGH MONEY TO BE FORCED
TO DEAL WITH THE TRANSIENT
SPOTLIGHT SEEKING THE LATEST RAW
MEAT.
I FEEL AMBIVALENT.
I KNOW I AM NOT SUPPOSED TO.
THIS IS A TERRIBLE STORY!
I AM OUTRAGED!
POLITICAL CORRECTNESS RUN A
MOCK.
>> Jesse: THAT'S WHAT YOU
WANTED.
>> Kimberly: SOMETIMES...
PERCOLATING BELOW THE SURFACE.
>> Juan: FIVE HOPEFULS WHO
DIDN'T MAKE IT BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T SCORE 87 OR HIGHER, BUT
THEY DID SCORE 78 TO 86.
THE SCHOOL SAID YOU CAN FOR
DISSIPATE.
>> Dana: OKAY.
I AM NOT OUTRAGED.
IT TAKES A LOT TO GET ME
OUTRAGED.
BUT I WILL SAY THEY'RE NOT DOING
THEM ANY FAVORS FOR WHEN THEY
ARE GOING TO ENTER THE JOB
MARKETS.
IT'S A SUPER COMPETITIVE WORLD
RIGHT NOW TO GET A JOB.
GUESS WHAT.
20 PEOPLE DON'T GET THE JOB.
ONE PERSON WILL GET THE JOB.
>> Greg: GOOD POINT.
AS A FORMER CHEERLEADER, YES.
I AGREE.
>> Juan: JESSE, WHAT ABOUT
POSITIVE REINFORCEMENT, LIKE
SAYING TO YOUNG PEOPLE, YEAH, WE
ARE GOING TO REWARD YOU FOR YOUR
EFFORT.
>> Jesse: IF EVERYBODY MAKES
THE TEAM, THEN YOU DON'T TRY
HARD TO MAKE THE TEAM.
>> Juan: NO, I WAS SAYING EVEN
PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING BUT DON'T
MAKE THE CUT ARE BEING
ENCOURAGED TO CONTINUE
PARTICIPATING.
>> Jesse: TOO BAD.
THAT'S WHY THEY HAVE THE TEAM.
YOU MAKE IT OR YOU DON'T MAKE
IT.
I HATE THIS STORY.
I THINK IT'S TOTALLY LAME.
WHEN WE WERE GROWING UP, THERE
WERE CUTS.
YOU FOUND OUT.
YOU WOULD LOOK ON THE SHEET.
YOU DIDN'T PLAY.
SORRY, MAYBE NEXT YEAR.
>> Dana: THAT ARE DETECTED.
THEN YOU DON'T HAVE TO WALK UP
AND LOOK.
>> Jesse: PEOPLE LOOK AND THEN
SCURRY AWAY.
>> Kimberly: DID YOU EVER NOT
MAKE SOMETHING?
>> Jesse: I GOT CUT IN
EIGHTH GRADE BASKETBALL.
BUT I WEASELED MY WAY ONTO THE
TEAM.
>> Juan: MICHAEL JORDAN GOT
CUT.
MICHAEL JORDAN DIDN'T QUIT.
THIS IS REALLY INTERESTING,
KIMBERLY.
>> Kimberly: THAT GREG IS A
CHEERLEADER AND NOT ME.
>> Juan: I THINK YOU COULD
HAVE BEEN IF YOU WANTED TO.
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
DANCE AND ART FOR CHEERLEADING
AND ACROBATIC CHEERLEADERS.
>> Jesse: JUAN IS IN THE
WEEDS.
>> Juan: WHO GETS POINTS AND
WHO DOESN'T.
DOESN'T MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE.
>> Kimberly: WHAT HAPPENS IS,
SOMETIMES YOU CAN HAVE, WE USED
TO HAVE AT MY SCHOOL.
WE HAD SONG GIRLS AND WE HAD
CHEERLEADERS.
THE CHEERLEADERS WOULD DO MORE
ACROBATICS, TUMBLING.
SONG GIRLS DID THE DANCE
ROUTINE.
IT WAS KIND OF SEPARATE.
YOU ALSO HAVE TO BE IN VERY GOOD
PHYSICAL SHAPE TO BE ABLE TO DO
THIS.
PYRAMIDS AND STUFF AND YOU CAN
FALL.
THEY DO FLIPS.
IT'S NOT THE EASIEST THING.
YOU'VE GOT TO BE IN SHAPE TO BE
ABLE TO DO IT.
>> Jesse: ISN'T CHEERLEADING
SEXIST?
THIS IS THE WHOLE THING.
WHAT ARE LIBERALS DOING?
COERCING YOUNG GIRLS.
>> Juan: HOW DO YOU KNOW THE
PRINCIPLE IS A LIBERAL?
>> Jesse: OH, COME ON.
>> Kimberly: I DON'T KNOW
WHERE HE WENT WITH THIS.
WHEN I WAS IN SECOND GRADE,
THERE WAS NO GIRLS TEAM FOR
SOCCER.
MY MOM CONVINCED THE COACH TO
GIVE ME A TRYOUT AND SAID IF SHE
IS GOOD ENOUGH AND SHE IS AS
GOOD AS ANY OF THE GUYS PLAYING,
THEN PUT HER ON THE TEAM.
IF SHE'S NOT, CUT HER.
I MADE THE TEAM.
I LIKED IT.
IT TAUGHT ME TO RELINE HER SOFT,
PRACTICE, WORK HARD AND DO IT.
EVENTUALLY THEY HAD A GIRLS
TEAM.
>> Greg: DO YOU REMEMBER ON
THE BRADY BUNCH WHEN PETER BRADY
BECAME A SUNFLOWER, GIRL SCOUTS.
THEN MARCIA BRADY JOINED THE
GIRL SCOUTS.
THAT WAS IN THE EARLY '70s.
>> Jesse: HOW OLD ARE YOU?